o pep é por dia e os povos feito o mundo
tem tudo confirmaria o amor do céu ea
terra cobertos com o cantar guia para o
sul
eu a riqueza para o canal da beleza
rasgante leste-oeste como teste do sul
ou sudeste só recebesse norte e nordeste
a vida o universo arranco roupas acerta
desculpas às imagens partido pranchas e
roupas usadas na cabeça às costas roma e
roberto marques combates de ramos
diversos ataques a tiros choques nas
bases do nosso trecho shica enfim nós
coxas a repetirem nomes é produzir os
seus clientes a parte dos microfones não
é obrigado rio de janeiro paga pra você
estiver aqui hoje fala
muito obrigado cara 6 que vieram aqui
hoje eu estou muito feliz de estar com
vocês vieram recebeu com aplausos o meu
tecladista o cara que vai botar trilha
sonora no nosso show caiu sesa palmas
para o caio césar da praia
obrigado por terem vindo que hoje está
com 3 mil habitantes tem o rio de
janeiro mais ou menos alguém perguntar
com alguma pessoa pode ser você está
mexendo no celular
quantos mil habitantes rio de janeiro
uma base mais ou menos não sabe dançar 6
milhões
é pra é muita gente a cidade que
eu nasci lá no piauí chama bom jesus do
piauí tem 30 mil habitantes
então é uma cidade relativamente pequena
só que a cidade que eu fui criado que em
santa luz no piauí
lá tem 2 mil habitantes então e agora
mora em são paulo são paulo tem 11
milhões
eu sei a diferença na cidade pequena com
a cidade grande
eu vivo isso direto tudo pra mim os
acidentes são diferente eu acho
diferente ela em são paulo eu vejo um
carro batido as pessoas elas ver o
acidente com o meu deus
ainda bem que não foi eu vou embora
pessoa no interior não no interior
parece que baixa o instituto
jornalístico na pessoa você vê esse
total atrasado de bicicleta o acidente
aconteceu se está passando mas meu de
luz a mãozinha pra trás
sempre tem um curioso que chegou o
primeiro a gente pergunta curioso né
porque isso aí foi que o cara responde
àquilo que você está vendo bateu o carro
pra que então não precisar são coisas do
interior é tudo diferente as festas são
diferentes
rio de janeiro vila mix é essa padrão é
a loc as coisas grande festa do interior
não é assim
é um caminhão com o prefeito a obra na
praça um tecladinho vai ter nem tem um
[Aplausos]
[Música]
as pessoas são engarrafados já franco
tem uma festa dessa a mulher eu acho
muito interessante que o cabelo dela vêm
até aqui o creme e até aqui
assim não tem dó do qual ele não tem com
ela para conversar chega pinga aqui no
chão tropeçar esbarrar nas costas dela
morreu afogado com creme diferente
a criança é totalmente diferente a
criança da cidade da criança no interior
tem nada a ver cada totalmente diferente
a criança da cidade que aqui tem um
comércio nome e começou num bruno que
mas a criança da cidade fala isso é
lindo eu acho sensacional
você chega no interior totalmente
diferente família meu pai tá em casa do
sul
ele vai sumindo na sombra para não ter
que responder ele vai nu é totalmente
diferente que você é o pai dele se é o
pai deles são mais o nome renato num
bonito renato eu tenho inveja de quem
chama renata e meu nome é difícil ficar
mas renato você tem cara de renato que
parece renato as pessoas parecem com o
nome dela
isso é interessante ricardo petista do
torricado parece para que cuida da saúde
bucal lourdes merendeira da escola gente
lourdes parece não parece maria de
lourdes e da luz trabalha na escola
também junto com ela é totalmente
diferente cada médico tem que ter nome
de médico
você não pode chegar no hospital o
médico jorge o sul não pode ser chegou
no hospital com a perna arrancada o nome
pgr o senhor vai me dar conhecimento
jogos é pedreiro
para jailson emenda minha perna agora
meu papel é mais assim
assim na perna e assim não pode
é ruim
eu presto muita atenção no nome de
piloto de avião porque o piloto onde é
bom o nome dele é junto com ele
para falar atenção senhores passageiros
quem fala o comandante as luxuosas nega
né
eu não voto nem sinto me sinto seguro
aquele cara ali onde eu fui pegar um vôo
brasília teresina para a atenção
senhores passageiros quem fala é o
comandante joaquim falei 'vou nada eu me
lembro sabe a rebocar as paredes aqui
morro de medo entrada em davi em alta
rafael frey aqui então não sei falar
renato bonito nome renato é pai de um
rapaz é difícil que a criança não
hoje em dia eu acho que está mais
difícil que antigamente que antigamente
se conseguirem gabela a criança para dar
um carrinho e dava um batatinha criança
am em brincava com abacate porque era o
que tinha ou vai brincar no brinca
hoje não a criança pede se oferece a
criança não quer tomar quem falei natal
ea boneca não queria dança que era uma
balaio
por que por que carga
antigamente no meu tempo quando era
criança não existia boneca desse jeito
só existir dois tipos de boneca som era
boneca que fechar o olho ea boneca que
não fechava o olho a criança rica tinha
boneca que fechar o olho criança pobre
que a mulher que ficava olhando o lado
assim só assim ela segurava o carro na
frente ou era pular a criança rica se
mostrava a minha boneca fez o anos e é o
pobre do vida das coisas
esse fechamento da etapa por essa boneca
morria assim só que às vezes ela vivia
com o engajado a voltava assim ó tinha
que bater na cabeça da boneca por voltar
totalmente diferente
mudava de mais cara carrinho ao carro só
tinha um tipo de carro quer um carro de
boi para aprender se fazendeiro já desde
criança já eu quero um carro vai com 6
80 no bar do boi vai levar boas sim e vi
um boi amarelo verde o azul eu nunca vi
um boi verde na minha vida naquele
carrinha aquela praga
ai ai que legal que trouxe seu filho pra
cá
obrigado por terem vindo aqui cara estou
muito feliz eu estava viajando muito
esses dias eu fiz isso na europa foi do
coisa linda conheci vários
lugares que eu não conhecia
eu conheci parecis cara merda das
pessoas tudo educada os cachorros e
educada em paris
cachorro chega pra mim já no poste e
outro por 12 em falar do pop já o
primeiro ocorre quando mixá o cachorro
em mg ainda assim ano depois a assim é
além do cara londres a coisa mais linda
que já vi na minha vida tudo é bonito e
logo o cemitério é bonito em londres
o cemitério é lindo cara eu estava vendo
aquela cor bonita passando assim eu a
chamo lhe daquelas coisas falou o
cemitério vai entrar vou ver como é
eu entrei estava tendo enterro que
ocorreu bato palma país inteiro então
não fora do normal tava tocando
musiquinha sim a música faz assim
soldado assim
[Música]
a coisa mais linda que eu já vi na minha
vida a mulher com véu as crianças
chorando baixo
eu nunca tinha visto o menino só assim é
que coisa linda
o a mais bonita que eu já vi na minha
vida sabe quantas pessoas no enterro
11 11 pessoas nem terminou e tenho todo
mundo saiu do zero uma palavra que
montar um relicário então livro porque o
desempenho do brasil não é assim
enterro nós tem 350 pessoas no enterro
só 10 conhece morto só os outros só
furioso e foquei facada foi matar foi
totalmente fé e as crianças estão nem aí
pra quem morreu não brincar com patadas
tomou 31 32 33 vai botar o caixão dentro
do buraco só me entendeu tav dados
o menino não tem sensibilidade às
crianças é totalmente diferente
foi triste aqui num pingue sensibilidade
às crianças e o enterro é da porta do
cemitério para dentro quem está fora
também está atenta e não botam
enterrando a pessoa meio-dia do lado de
fora tá rolando um churrasco é a partir
a tudo e acabar é mulher de muita
sensibilidade
que morreu nem aí para o ne yo -
eu acho interessantíssimo isso cara ai
eu adorei
eu gostei demais você já sai do brasil
renato foi legal quando você foi a
orlando miami
eu fui também os senhores aqui na frente
mas o nome será como maria que o tempo
só que a maioria não tinha muito muito a
opção não é a dona maria dona maria
eu acho legal muito obrigado ser evitado
ana maria
eu fui saber aonde nádia foi rolando
também foi atingido na nuca alho
a disney massa porque cena que brinca na
montanha-russa de verdade lá tem
montanha-russa de verdade seguir maia
não temos seguro vai assim ó você vai
chega lá o cara foi bom foi bom foi bom
a lágrima aqui na hungria lágrima ç ã
alemanha e rússia de verdade nessa
dessa lagarta rede na cidade da gente né
serra foi no parque montanha russa por
da lagarta é maconheiro
só passava lá gata é assim parece que
estão dando comida lagar é triste
eu acho triste você leva a criança para
se divertir para meu filho está lá gata
vai você bota mineiro assegura assim o
menino ea mãe falei isso aqui mesmo na
segunda que agora vai alta faz aqui
o menino na primeira volta em movimento
e 10/8 humano com o sapo
o menino então atriz sai com depressão
de dará ao rio brinquedo mais radical
que nos parte do brasil é a barca em
parafuso
taí uma barra de ferro é o menino triste
e eu não tenho medo do brinquedo que
abraão
eu tenho medo do cara que opera o
brinquedo seja arquibancada que
imaginava para passar com o trade que
saiu da cadeia e um dente de ouro cabelo
chitãozinho e xororó 1990 tatuagem não
da mãe no braço maria aqui é triste
morro de medo mas eu gostei viajei pra
viajei muito
assim que eu comecei a ganhar dinheiro
fosse meu irmão vou conhecer o mundo
inteiro de morrer comecei a viajar e
agente fifa foi o avaí do avaí
caminha muito só que é longe demais 11
horas de vôo o avaí dos estados unidos
daqui eu não sei nem o tanque de óleo de
voo muito longe eu tenho medo de andar
de avião da portela quando o necessidade
eu tenho medo eu vou comprar passagem
ruas pedir uma passagem foi avaí se
acertar onde vai ter como você está na
caixa preta do avião e não só a caixa
preta quando caiu o avião sumiu mas
encontramos a caixa feito no oceano saiu
em cima se na caixa preta
eu vou sentar para ver morrer nessa
média eu tenho medo de falar a verdade
não vou falar a mentira você crê que a
pessoa que vende a passagem da escola
não quer que você boi que botar medo
face me deu o número de emergência
a lei para que o poema urgência foi na
época de emergência nenhum aqui mas em
caso de emergência ligar para alguém de
clipe pra mim o meu número então a ligar
pra minha mãe assegurar o avião não vai
se mudar
eu entrei dentro do avião cara eu sentei
do lado de um velho estava rezando falar
acabou vazando no coração do velho é
matar mais perto de deus a oração dele
né ela entregue em mãos a deus vai muito
feia pra
muito muito muito feliz em ver que o
pescoço a cabeça aqui no peito fica
assim já assim que não consegue parar de
falar que essa posição não quer essa
merda papai noel ea perna já é torta
ela vai pra muito muito velhos
20 anos mais novo que a maria o pouca
coisa mas ele lá escuta maneira e eu sei
do lado dele estava rezando muito alto
para falar você compra este avião
inteiro com teu manto sagrado senhor eu
fiquei agoniada falemos pelo amor de
deus pede lhe para deixar eles começam a
visão dos pilotos me feliz
e envolveu inteiro é isso é o caminho
cheguei no avaí só nessa acção contínua
na minha vida que eu pensei 'meu filho
pode revelar pagou ontem rio também
quando eu pago entre assim já a valer o
dinheiro que eu paguei tem cinema ao
lado final e ai ai eu cheguei nova eu me
decepcionei
o que eu pensei que eu ia chegar e até
aquela mulher com a floram a lona afim
tinha por nenhuma não tinha um ano
luís tite não existir muita japonês lá
chega e japonês
fui lá ver japonês pra ver cheguei lá a
gente japonês porque é perto pra eles
entendeu é como se fosse fortaleza
eles vão assim bem rápido cheio de chapa
e eu fiquei observando eu acho
interessante japonês conversando mas que
está brigando
ele pode estar dizendo eu te amo e é
para a obra da arena a
você vai bater na mulher no meio da rua
que o irmão começar lá dentro
bota um fone sei lá
agora uma coisa que ele sabe fazer é
comer sushi porque eles inventaram ele
sabe que tem uma maestria para comer eu
ficava olhando e comendo sushi eles
conversa pega um papelzinho que fica
assim não sei que a gente faz aqui não
a gente consegue pegar a missão é um só
botar dentro da boca que cai quebra o
prato é só isso
só não foi legal o avaí foi do
foi bacana mas o que eu mais gostei foi
os estados unidos eu gostei dos estados
unidos pra pois tem muito tempo
esses parques aí que eu fui lá e depois
que eu não gostei um ponto negativo para
mim foi a comida porque o nosso cachorro
quente aqui é com muita coisa a gente
bota o que tiver dentro o que estiver
perto a gente joga falar a verdade eu
estava comendo cachorro quente uma tampa
e ao mês o que você insere a little no
hotel x enfarto entendeu e se permite
comer um cachorro quente da áfrica que
ele colesterol no fundo aqui você fazer
assim e eu cheguei lá nos estados unidos
um cachorro quente é um pão e uma
salsicha som
eu fiquei indignado cana além de um
cachorro quente a mulher entregou falou
que acha que o cachorro quente e fala eu
mesmo faço aqui não seja a do milho
embora e ficar de milho quero pagar para
ver alguma coisa do milho
eu quero ver o ranking
seu canal no vermelho no cume
já o feijão alguma coisa em cima pra
sair né
mas uma coisa eu gostei pra foi
o cachorro cachorro dos estados unidos é
porque não obedece o dono
isso é lindo seja um graveto achou
ocorre o graveto traz até você se pega
falar até com o smiles que é nosso
cachorro faz isso não
a gente joga o palco show falou buscar
essa meta principal verão a buscar você
você chegou quando fui eu
é um cachorro que é duas vezes maior de
jogo paulo ele corre global embora falar
e planejar a vida dele ele o pau só você
não está incluído lutaria cara tem um
cachorro é 3 maior do que o nosso jogo
pau ele corre pego paulo traz até perto
você fala assim meu cachorro é diferente
quando chega o pessoal me down paulo
defar dj né
cachorros estados unidos rama o dono
isso é interessante de mais trabalho
para guerra passa cinco anos a guerra
ele volta o cachorro se lembra com
saudade do cara
pula em cima chora mídia pra cima delas
coisa bonita nossos cachorros vamos com
o papão é cinco minutos só se volta com
a sacola de pão se estava destrancado
portão cachorro estava lá dentro de si
na ciência ele vacilar vai embora dessa
agora deixa o abridor de dá mais
ele se abra a porta cachorro começa a
gritar em casa que a família fica
que o cachorro foi embora
marina saiu de novo lá vem a maria
pacheco da rosa fala pra cuidar do
photoshop inglês a chutar a bola vou
deixar essa só dentro de casa
aí começa a gritaria a família faz um
mutirão navio sai todo mundo de trás do
carro abaixo dos carros
boston é o nome que a gente bota em
cachorro né
bosta que bosta vida do nosso cachorro é
tentar fugir
já a prestar atenção quando a família
encontrou o cachorro todo mundo volta a
ficar muito feliz - um cachorro
eu adoro cachorros o fã de cachorro pra
caramba sou fone cachorro eu ganhei um
cachorro e se chama mora não sei se
vocês conhecem pelo dinheiro seja ver é
lindo de marketing cachorro só que eu
não queria ela porque é o seguinte o mal
de você gostar de cachorro é que as
pessoas acham que você tem a obrigação
de ficar com todos os que existe no
mundo entendeu então o cachorro da
mulher pariu ligou pra mim falou em
ficar com o cachorro falei cara não é
porque eu fui explicar por que tomaram
em são paulo agora um apartamento muito
pequena é só trabalhar mesmo dormir e
viajar então com um cachorro fica ruim
foi explicar para ela foi morar em
apartamento que ela não dá é muito ruim
um cachorro caem tudo quebra as coisa e
come sofá e move as coisas mídia nas
coisas que tudo cheio de cachorro hoje
em dia você tem que cuidar do cachorro
eu viajo pra não dá pra mim eu
viajo muito tempo como da tensão
cachorros e não dá atenção do cachorro
hoje em dia o que achou da depressão no
cachorro fica aquela coisa diferente e
eu falei um dá a cara enquanto estiver
morando em apartamento não posso ficar
com o cachorro ela falou williams
cachorro da raça mais caro do mundo é 10
mil reais um filhote eu falei o que é um
apartamento sem um cachorro na chácara
klabin
eu vou pegar esse cachorro a nossa casa
tão vazia bicho falar a verdade
ela falou ea depressão falou também
tempo normal isso aí a gente se ajuda
foi uma festa juntos foi na casa dela
pegou o cachorro cheguei em casa
tremendo cachorro deve enviar na
mãozinha
gostei paulo izzo o amor ganha nunca
chuva de 10 mil reais ao ano ea luís
apaixonada pelo meu deus que cachorro
lido nós vamos criar falei com o edu vou
tocar num celta cachorro cachorro vai
perder valor com o tempo posso arriscar
achou cagada eu juntava se você tava
aqui ó
assim tá doido e aí ficando com o
cachorro adota mais um depois eu eu
adoro cachorros
eu sou muito fã de cachorro de todo tipo
de cachorro - o pinte o pitcher não
porque não adianta fazer a todo mundo
que faz a tem 11 fitch ele ama o dono
ele odeia o resto do mundo inteiro deu
aquele cachorro é um demônio
eu acho que o satanás assumir o
rottweiler pitt estava passando pegou na
hora porque ele vibra no templo tem como
um cachorro vibrar é o único que vibra é
o pente ele começa a tiac e também não
tinha talento já parece aquela máquina
de escrever quando chega no final tem
que fazer puxar pra cá de novo não tem
punição e ele não consegue localizar a
vítima dele porque 18 ele aponta a falar
outra conta pra cá muito aí eu juro eu
tento me socializar com 26 na casa
pessoal quero passar a mão nele
só que ele não admira
eu chego faço aqui ó
eita o num o essa espada jaime é um
cachorro a gente desiste não esse é o
problema a gente continua o que a gente
quer saber qual o limite que pode chegar
nele
então você vai assistir o demônio é o
satanás
você vai chegando perto sabe que
acontece ele continua arrasando só que
quando você chega muito perto dele
ele começa a rosnar de lado
é aí que eu tenho medo porque não sei o
que ele vai fazer diferente eu tô pronto
o fato junto com ela que agora quando
está de lado e começa a doença
[Música]
chega um momento que ele sabia tanto ele
começa a querer falar tomado com mari é
natural porque ele faz isso porque ele
faz isso ele explica agora ele sabe que
ele não te mata da mordida de um susto
ele mata vai chegando muito perto
concentrado ele faça meu amigo a alma dá
uns quatro passos para trás assim só que
ela volta com o corpo
não tem como explicar no céu o morro do
latido um brinde não tem como
morreu dinheiro para mais uma fera e
isso é um problema se mostra o dono da
casa está com medo do cachorro da casa
da mãe é vergonha isso que a gente faz
cria uma cena mais vergonhosa ainda que
essa aqui ó pra mim a reação da gente é
essa no momento em que mora
o vacilo
o tom foi muito rápido
ele gosta de mim ele vai ficar a site da
daí pra frente e começa ignorar o
cachorro
toda vez que chega um gato ou cachorro
enquanto você passa assim você não pode
chutar por chutar mata deu então por
isso penso que não
o pane eu tenho medo eu tenho medo
porque você chega na casa da pessoa a
pessoa fala foi o meu cachorro um pague
bem o papel
eu falei eu vou brincar ele vai enfartar
vão pensar que eu matei não vou falar do
medo o salsicha eu gosto e salsicha
a jovem ter um futuro somente aí só se
chega a alta porque ele não vi ele
realmente parece a salsicha é problema
quando ele cresce fica velha fica
parecendo a mortadela assim que o
cachorro velho a gente conhece
você conhece o cachorro é pelo latido
você não precisa ver se chega na casa um
cachorro vai ser assim
mas saiu houver um baby doll face mel e
todo cachorro velho chama mel ele novo
pode chamar hulk vem e mel que chama
todo cachorro robert momento a tal cara
do riso né esse aval sem ver seu nome
eduardo ea eduardo e natália igor de
coisa atrasada
é bom né volta e meia é o cara só
das 111 sampa passar um cartãozinho ela
já tava da mulher baixo a pegar em armas
já o casal
eu adoro acho muito legal
existe uma grande diferença da relação
sexual do ser humano para o cachorro
vou te dizer qual é agora o ser humano e
precisa de uma palavra só chama
intimidade e intimidade você precisa na
casa de vocês e entendeu o quarto de
vocês uma porta para trancar o momento
vocês dois se chama intimidade o
cachorro não
maria cachorro trabalhando no teu olho
arena
ele não tá nem aí que a gente acha
engraçado está no meio da voz cachorro
transando e fica assim o que resultará
[Aplausos]
se for um pint se for um punk rock
o pó olha a transado com vida no pânico
ai adoro cachorros
ae quanto tempo estão juntos há dois
anos a dois anos é legal eu tô há dois
anos também era muito bom o
relacionamento ness e discutem vez em
quando isso é normal todo mundo escutar
porque o casal tem que ser assim um
diferente do outro
o meu eu acho o seguinte eu namoro com a
menina que é do rio grande do sul noivo
dela e é o lugar mais gelada do brasil e
eu sou do piauí
sou um lugar que eu sou nossa sim pra
gente assim entendeu só dorme com raiva
corda com ódio lá às vezes atua em porto
alegre
vamos lá então para indicar a cidade
dela muito gelada fala amor pelo amor de
deus
o piauí em parnaíba
vamos curtir uma praia o homem mais
directo que a mulher nas coisas eu acho
como dizer um exemplo é quando é pra
praia um chinelo short mãos uma blusa
acabou há mas são 15 dias não tem
problema nenhum
ao lado de noite dos pelados a mesma
roupa do dinheiro
a mulher não há mulher que vai viajar na
hora de fazer a mala ela cria um monte
de situações que não vão acontecer para
levar mais coisas na mala
cheguei no quarto valoriza fazendo a
mala tentando botar um casaco dentro da
mala
o que é isso falou um casaco o piauí um
casaco
ela olhou na minha cara que diz assim
vai o tempo muda a lei pelé a frozen
sofre sozinho a mudar o tempo amor e 80
no clima do peão mesmo a mulher que
menos trabalho na televisão brasileira é
a mulher do tempo do jornal do piauí que
ela entra na televisão é fácil salvar
sai é só isso que tento não vai mudar
a chuva na nuvem o novo leva um salto à
praia
a planta milho na praia vai fazendo
assim com salto assim eu vou atrás só
entrar na simpatia não tem condição que
eu acho que o homem mais direto nas
coisas nesse quesito não entendeu quando
se fala nesse quesito
você fala assim mas não quis tecer
eduardo foi doado por que não gosta é de
fulano
adoro falar assim paulo coco nome dele
não me chegou chegou minha mãe chegou
ninguém mas não guardei a mulher que não
goste de outra ela vai na festa a fulana
lá falou que essa meta fazendo aqui
se eu soubesse tinha linda a festa pra
mim acabou
a curva eu odeio essa mulher falou mal
de mim da minha mãe da minha amiga ela
vem aqui eu não dou nenhum e mulher tudo
quanto é que tá rapaz tá bonita né
[Música]
é uma parte que o homem vita
isso quer dizer que seja uma coisa boa
que entendeu que o homem é burro
vocês estão juntos graças a ela que o
homem é duplo
vamos saber se disse uma tcheca o cara
conversa com a mulher fique esperto já é
o cara site fala assim penso que não
viram né ela na tua cara fazem viu o que
é ligado à tarde
a gente não sabe se expressar em
palavras a mulher vê também sente ciúme
ela vem com as pontas pergunta
hipotética que apontam ótimo eu tenho
mode quantos de vocês estão namorando
aqui já ouviu isso aqui do nada tá
assistindo filmes é que o amor à
disposição
se anita aparecesse pelada na tua frente
o que faria eu não olha essa brincadeira
que eu não goste essa brincadeira ela
fala não vai a brincadeira que é que o
faria falar morreu imediatamente pegar
uma toalha
a anita por favor do clube senão de
jesus é fazer mas essa é a resposta que
ela não quer ouvir falar em amor
anita mangueira livre na verdade né cara
ela começa a ficar com raiva o primeiro
que merda foi que deu muito bonita para
eu falar da minha frente foi o vencedor
foi aconteceu em voga o paraná também
para a minha frente com aparecendo
quando fala que eu faria falou tá bom eu
olhar na pronto aí morreu e olhar pronto
olhar
só olha só mata ninguém né
[Música]
beleza
daí pra frente a tua vida anita só
amores que se atua esta pede ali ela
fala de hoje para eu não gosta da
brincadeira
não gosto dessa brincadeira
ae a vida da mulher mais difícil que a
do homem só admita mulher muito
guerreiro para o homem muito a vida é
fácil para o mimi beija muito fácil
pode ser algum caminhão aqui agora você
não sabe que a mulher não a mulher não
vai viajar ela levanta o espírito de
coletividade bom que ela levanta a visão
femininas
eu não sei vocês eu tô indo viajar ela
se compadece aqui está na frente mas eu
também vou mijar também aplicado lá para
votar e fala-se agora é a hora de mijar
elas dão para não falar em java vou
mijar parece que o frequentam
quebra-cabeça cada um tem um pedaço
tadeu chega no banheiro que monto mega
soja que a fome já viajando é muito
diferente um décimo do carro está
viajando aqui embaixo vida que mija pelo
vídeo assim quem tiver bem na prova de
moto fala meu deus chovendo piauí joana
a mulher não eu viajava com a mãe
eu viajava com a mãe mamãe dirigir outro
lado aqui no pezinho 5 sentir mãe pagava
pé da moita abre a porta para o jantar
da porta para ninguém ver e eu tinha que
ficar atrás da mãe avisando se alguém
estava vindo meu primeiro emprego foi
esse
realizador de mills da mãe era eu
vamos falar pode aprender muito afirmou
mota mãe de passar por lá os cantos da
moto vindo sabiá
[Música]
a mamãe vai numa embaixada estava assim
foi aí que eu percebi que o barulho
domingo da mulher muda conforme a
pressão que ela está sentindo
estava assim os alemães que estava em
uma moto que estava na moto e um carro
peixes
eu me senti sintonizando a rádio
qualquer momento é fazer xixi esse cara
sou eu jurava alemão estava na moto um
carro e um caminhão e é rápido e se
preferir uma metalúrgica que saiu foi
spring no chão um buraco globo da
potência com o tempo
quero um jato viram cachoeira em um
córrego
é mais difícil a vida da mulher
eu juro é fácil disfarçar se alguém pega
no flagra camila no muro chega alguém
falou isso aí o cara o vasoc o número a
mulher não há mulher que entrega o que
já não seria assim como ela é ruim a
outra coisa que a mulher tem ou não tem
que é o controle da vontade de kaká a
mulher tem esse controle é sábio escuta
sempre escuta me sentindo tão cheia
porque há oito dias que eu nunca vi
o homem existe estão o homem permita à
vontade em falar rapaziada da gávea nem
eu tô a gente pensa força para segurar o
meu
um dia depois o rio open mail
vazou pelo pinto é que ele é totalmente
assim estranho para aquela coisa né
mas que legal que estão justamente vocês
podem assistir filme que tipo de filmes
vão existir fora os passos que está no
cinema não tá aí pra ir no filme
obrigado obrigado é sucesso aí inclusive
quando sair daqui vou assistir tá não
não hoje amanhã hoje a gastar o dinheiro
já peguei de você já tá ação filme de
ação você goste que a comédia é o de
qualquer tipo de filme
eu não gosto de filme mentiroso filme
que mente é que não gosto eu tá romã se
mente demais não tava vendo um filme de
romance que o cara estava caminhando
esbarrou na mulher derrubou os livros
que ele abaixou para pegar olhou para
ela se apaixonou
assim é desse jeito a prestação ela
estava caminhando você é meu deus a
minha aula de astrologia vou pertencer a
chance você desculpa sem querer o
[Música]
eu acho que conheço de algum lugar
ela falou trabalho num cabaré que atrás
a gente pegar na mão sair o apaixonado
isso não existe não existe isso existe a
pessoa canta atrasada apressar a
estressada
ninguém se apaixona o cara de verdade
que está atrasada e encaminhamos barco a
que pariu perdeu o único do meia
roubar a mulher fica no chamado até à
covilhã da eu vou eu lhe disse olha
a faca a tudo que pai e filha da
porras apostila branquinha cara eu
deixei de terra o livro geografia
estudar em 3d agora relevo não é é é o
filme hispano tipo de terror
a gente tem medo da história e tem medo
da música é a música que dá medo
se você fala assim duas crianças na rua
deserta não dá medo
esse país aqui ó duas crianças
uma rua deserta
aí dá medo
na verdade é que ficou parecendo
abertura da caixa preta nem sabe a gente
pode nos mandar banda calcinha preta
declarou seu amor e vira manchete dos
jornais
eu faço tudo
[Música]
o gol
o batom
[Música]
maria você
a gente se diverte né cara
é muito bom ai calcinha preta que era a
banda cara ali era massa que tinha letra
tinha letra de uma música da calcinha
preta falava como adão e eva no sus no
pará isso é bíblico com as empresas
a voz que hoje em dia a música que faz
sucesso é meu pai te ama música é uma
mentira paulo amanhã o dono dele no ano
é de que aquele homem não quer mas
naquele dia não entendia quem está na
fila da caixa lotéricas meio dele como é
chamado na água vai subindo o rio vai
voltando ao filme de terror tem uma
coisa que eu não gosto de filme de
terror
a mãe nunca acredita nos filho eu digo
uma coisa vocês criança vê a alma
a criança respira eu tenho que primeiro
vão lá pra casa com ela para a derrapar
lado engraçado aqui de um chute eu tenho
medo e as primeiras pessoas que viajavam
no filme é a criança ea mãe não acredita
que a mãe nunca acredita nas crianças
tava no filme o menino entrou no
banheiro ela abriu a porta e viu a moça
com sangue na barriga uma visão né
ele foi contar à mãe
ele chegou na cozinha ele falou com a
mãe
mamãe mamãe mamãe sim eu vi uma moça no
banheiro uma mãe com spring na barriga e
os cabelos de araci da papéis
a mãe do meu pai ele falou assim não
diante não não fiquei com aquela
história mirabolantes que a macaca foi
morto
já para conhecer hoje vamos começar com
aqueles k aki taboão bom isto não quer
dizer que isso é assim né
se fosse comigo meu deus chega meu filho
pra mim falou papai eu vivo no chão do
banheiro com sangue na barriga e falar
meu filho pelo amor de deus a partir de
hoje todo mundo aqui em casa vai cagar
na cozinha agora tá
não vou fazer confusão com o demônio
casa de um banheiro não né
o besteirol posso muito bem cada na
sacola já do outro lado do muro
ele é saber que essa merda é minha hora
esse é o problema das pessoas dos filmes
mas quer discutir com o demônio porque
chega ao demônio tocado com essa casa é
minha de assumir o batom embora agora o
besteira hora pronto não precisa
discutir essa raiva que eu tenho de
filme de terror com as pessoas do filme
nunca faz aquilo que a gente faria nesse
mesmo filme o menino que viu a mulher
desceu do quarto dele de madrugada
desceu todas as escadas foi até a
cozinha não acendeu uma lâmpada da casa
a partir daí eu já comecei a torcer pelo
demônio já paga uma taxa de estado seed
of como é que consegue a luz que a gente
quando vai na cozinha a gente vai ser
nem todos assim não vai aqui se fala
assim porque quem faz isso porque a
gente faz isso eu vou lhe dizer agora a
gente faz isso que a gente sabe que não
tem demônio na cozinha
a gente sabe que não tem espírito no
banheiro imagem também não quer arriscar
é isso aí tá viajando aqui de boa assim
o filezinho jan
é como se o mundo tivesse escondido
fosse levantar 100 lamia show num e sair
mas a gente tenha precaução e como
menino não acendeu uma luz da casa que
aconteceu no caminho para beber água
ele parou olhou escuro do nabo um
carrinho que ele tinha de boi vai até
ele bem devagarzinho caem sozinho assim
vindo de uma caminhada no sol
ele ficou ali anos
se fosse comigo a velocidade que se a
gente tivesse vier a velocidade da minha
merda escorrendo na perna que acho que
na hora do medo o primeiro músico que
saltou do culpa dessa aquele mel e
começar como lá no meu pé não gostar de
modo que eu tava comecei a ficar jogando
a bola para trás assim de repente na
hora de correr escorregou na minha
própria boca né pessoal me achar amor de
mãe ao todo cagado chan
eu morro de medo recarregada ao não
encontrar a causa da morte também não
querer investigar não deixa todo cagado
vai deixar morrer o que o cara a cara
negra caganeira da china não foi o
demônio ou demônio quer que o menino do
filme faz o animal pega o carrinho jogo
de volta
[Música]
quando o carro chega no escuro ele
escuta a voz assim ó sem brincar comigo
[Música]
quem foi meu amigo faça um pouco dessa
comigo não tá no meu de madrugada eu
escuto vem brincar comigo a do torneio
ao lado
elas brincam danças o meu cabelo começa
a crescer
aparece uma saia a bíblia virar mulher
da assembléia de deus na mesma hora eu
vejo que eu podia jogar o carro eu podia
jogar também
talvez mas se eu jogasse e escrever um
bilhete antes eu ia fechar o bilhete
cortar entre dois bois pega demônio
jogava quando o satanás abril o bilhete
assim tá amarrado em nome de jesus
eu tenho medo ao filme que eu mais gosto
é o pornô o forno eu gosto por nilmar e
andrezinho só ai ai nem se o eta só eu
andar por não ver o meu pai me briga com
muito
eu só não gosto de filme pornô porque
não condiz muito a minha realidade aqui
que o povo é um ator pornô não é normal
não é de deus
eu acho que são criados na granja
ela joga ração pra eles
aduba rola para crescer mais
não é normal eu estava mexendo aqui no
celular é um dia
luiza do meu lado aqui sentado aqui eu
mexer naquilo celac tranquila no grupo
do do futebol os caras só manda votar em
mim o futebol
aloísio mandou do nada eu ia apertar na
foto apareceu em um vídeo e dê o play no
vídeo apareceu paria uma senhora bomba
desse tamanho não pesou eu players in
sao ea luiza viu quando ela olhou
afundou meio desde existe um negócio
desse tamanho
a leitora é doido aqui a montagem do
terminal a levar o meu não é que a gente
se ilude com a gente a adolescente
aceite por nossa empresa que vai ser
daquele jeito eu com 12 eu não tomava
banho falar isso aqui vai ser uma roupa
ou tirar fotos ou mandar no grupo da
família galera
mas não foi o que aconteceu isso comigo
estava lá em casa um apartamento na
luiza malhando na academia do do prédio
lá embaixo
terminou em março subiu falou tomar um
banho não rende e suada aqui beleza ela
foi no banheiro trancou a porta que ele
parou de chover o que sei fazer nada e
também não vou ficar sem fazer nada a
guiné está passando aqui na rede vida é
o televisão fora do ar falou é jesus que
aconteceu em um computador menina pegou
o computador o computador já sabe o que
eu quero meu computador da casa botas em
w x vídeo em baixo assim é tem vergonha
de emprestar sabe só deixa eu fazer uma
pesquisa para o que é que você quer ver
que o bota aqui
eu dei um play no vídeo pornô todo filme
pornô território antes né
ainda há já também não chega já né então
a história a mulher tinha pedido pizza
meio dia não tem pizzaria aberta ora dez
estão enganando você mulher chegou
entregador de pizza sem camisa com a
pizza aqui
falacianos foi daqui que pedir uma pizza
ea mulher dentro assim fui eu que pedi
uma pizza alencar área é muito boa
sobretudo furtos
eu nunca perguntei pra minha mãe tem um
almoço arroz com frango ou arroz com
franco retorna a culpa nunca fez
aí ele resolveu abrir a pizza por ele
apita amarrou a fa cup com um fosse
interessante é bater na minha cara
fiquei impressionado
triste aí eles começaram a fazer as
coisas casal normal não faz né
pegou a mulher botou no joelho botou no
mundo jogou pra cima param na rua tucumã
cicinho voltou a manhã em cima blade
rodou em cima vai adorar fazer isso aí
quebra logo à nascença na primeira
fiquei impressionado com aquilo que é a
imagem da minha cabeça
a manhã terminou tomar banho e saiu do
banheiro foi morto com fome para pedir
uma pizza foi o cara que você vai pedir
uma pizza
você me fez em nome da fifa é um cara
muito fácil de sair de casa do pai fifa
é triste que todo o filme que a gente
assiste sem se imagina do filme só que
eu não tinha suspeitos daquele caso
oferecer a galera onde acho que o máximo
que oferecerem foi aqui pedir um churros
fazer assim é mordida ainda pode açúcar
o leite condensado no atacado 2
ovinho de codorna embaixo
se quiser né dona maria
eu quando era criança o menino muito
danado quando você tem um rapaz de 10
anos era exatamente a idade que tinha
quando eu tinha 10 anos quando eu tinha
10 anos eu era um menino muito danado
hoje eu sou comportado aprende com a
vida mas quando eu era criança não era
senão quando era criança era danado
mentia muito eu comia tudo em casa tinha
um problema tem um irmão outro irmão e
uma irmã e o que aconteceu à mãe
comprava sempre coisas iguais para todo
mundo é um bom pra mim pro meu outro
irmão pro meu outro irmão pra minha irmã
só que eu como o meu e deles ao passar
do tempo eu sempre comer minhas coisas
dele meu irmão começar a emagrecer e eu
com dez anos aparecendo tecladista que
já é mamãe falou que está acontecendo
foi uma mãe não sei que tá acontecendo
uma mãe começou a fazer saber que maria
esconder as coisas da minha casa mãe
toda vez que saía para trabalhar pegava
voltava tudo que era de criança como
escondido em cima de um armário grande
pegava nescau leitinho mucilon essas
coisas todas
botava em cima da estante e eu já sabia
onde estava o mal da criança e se saber
onde está a mãe saiu para trabalhar
somente a mãe pode ir tranquilo
eu já não sei nem vou enganar agora mãe
saiu para trabalhar comecei a procurar
coisa para subir em cima as cadeiras da
pesada não conseguir a mesma muito
pesado não conseguiu mexer também eu
falei vou olhar dentro do armário eu
abrir o armário cheio de brasília da mãe
falei vou subir em cima de uma vasilha
peguei a vasilha tentando leu no rótulo
topel auri dupla vários a quimera ele
voltei no chão subir em cima eu tinha 10
anos ea quebrar né
só que eu fiz assim e não chegou falei
vou pegar outra
só que os atuais parece que falou que
pega mais três
peguei três botei em cima e ficar quatro
ou subir em cima deu aquela e equilibrei
foi assim
oscilam
a lei é hoje que eu vou comer mucilon
que inclui não deu falta um pouquinho
pra beirada da vasilha
eu fui e não deu foi afastando afastando
bastante o satanás vem vai dar certo vem
bem cheguei demais na beirada da vasilha
desequilibrei ela deslizou
quando eu inclinei para pegar o exemplo
elas foram eu para não cair
segurei na estante bate numa bandeja com
seis xícaras chega normal não mantinha
ganhar de casamento 17 anos atrás nunca
tinha tomado uma água morna
naquela chuva parece que na hora do
aperto satanás pega chica rui bota
especial no lugar que ela chega ninguém
diria que era intocável
chegava uma pessoa fosse pegar achei que
a mãe saia de do armário falava e dentro
do campo não era a guardiã da chipa eu
bati de um mata bandeja o outro subiu
jogou a 6 fica para sempre
[Música]
escutei pela música
mande notícias fluido de lotes que fica
me deu um abraço é apertar até chegar
an o olhar para o lado e vi a zaga
passando por mim suportam se abre nas
água potável para dentro do portão
lá dentro a hebe camargo acenava para
mim
chamava mais o jec e nem sabia
ele sabia que eu ia morrer quando chega
finalmente caiu no chão e quebrou foi pa
eu escutei meu irmão ea se lascar daqui
porque o irmão da gente só quer o mal da
gente não tem nenhum irmão não existe
uma situação ruim
ele olha para você passar a mão nas suas
costas do irmão
deus é contínuo
ele é na sua cara sorrindo e fazendo
sabe quando a mãe chegar vai morrer e
ele já está pensando e ficado pelos
benzia acordos e nick pista e já quer
quando elvira chega acaba no chão falar
acabou para mim acabou
achei vou morrer eu vou morrer eu vou
morrer
comecei minha agonia não sei se já
prestar atenção ao filho do pobre quando
começa a chorar do meio do choro pra
frente ele fica foi um do meio pra
frente fácil não acredito que amanhã me
matar o gado a amanhã a mínima
a e dança com um
era assim
eu comecei agoniar falei 'vou morrer eu
vou morrer eu vou morrer ou morriam
acreditar vou morrer não 1965 minuto
desentendimento e morrer
sabe o que aconteceu cinco dias depois
eu comecei a me acostumar com a idéia da
morte levando o vermelho e aí morreu
morreu
todo mundo morre ou besteira
também já vivem muitos já dez anos a bom
ou estável negociado a casa realmente me
embora também não morrer morremos não
foi muito dodô eu tô nem aí mão à cara
do cara ai tô nem aí não então eu vou
embora vou para a colômbia mesmo o
profissão repórter vai lá e aí como é a
vida do craque de grupos o craque não
são mas você vai para aquele que braun
chico da mamãe olha aí não é bom
quebro mesmo uma mãe chegar aqui fala
meu deus a minha chico que foi isso de
quebrei um tabu porque ele porque o case
fui com o meu gol silom perdeu a bola em
cima de mim aqui embaixo de travar essa
merda marcado
o rei morreu o bicheiro para que essa
ganância era ficar velho precisa
isso é muito dói e foi muito tom em que
também morreram dez anos é mesmo
são paulo uma mãe não me mata
eu fui falar com a única pessoa podia
ouvir naquele momento
olhei pra cima eu falei deus
[Música]
jesus
deus já sozinho
ae
falei deus senhor não conhece minha mãe
não deus e esse foi o erro
eu não conhecia jesus como eu conheço
hoje
hoje eu conheço jesus eu tenho certeza
que todo mundo aqui conhece
independente da sua religião católica e
evangélica ou se você é ateu
você já ouviu falar de jesus você
conhece só que como eu era criança
pra mim só chegou às histórias
transformar água em vinho ressuscitou
lázaro caminhou sobre as águas falei
isso que eu quero
esse é que é bom a transformar água em
vinho vai recomendar chicamba e metal
e como eu não conhecia a autoridade de
deus sabe a grandiosidade de deus que eu
fiz o que desafiar a lei então adeus bom
coisa boa né
citou deus mesmo
você vai recomendar meia chega pra mim
agora eu vou conferir
vou ficar de costas pra dar um tempo do
milagre falar se vou conferir 10 anos
marrento querem ter razão que o menino
pode ter razão
peguei a primeira xícara inteira
falei muito bom obrigado
voltei na bandeja eu peguei a segunda
chega estava inteira de muito obrigado
jesus desculpa eu cheguei todo ignorante
aqui estressado que a gente sai da
agência no stress mas muito obrigado
botei
eu peguei a terceira xícara estava
inteira fala bem aventurada as crianças
disse
porque delas é o reino dos céus e 80
bandeja
eu peguei a quarta x ab inteira
a lei ainda que eu ande pelo vale da
sombra da morte não temerei não algum e
botei na bandeja
eu peguei a quinta chega sob inteira eu
falei mil xícaras caíram à sua esquerda
10 mil à tua direita nenhuma vai
quebrasse
[Música]
botei na bandeja
eu peguei a cesta chega e mãe têm andado
atribulado mas estava inteiro
só que tinha quebrado a orelha da
chicane
falei pai por que me abandonaste quando
não estou reclamando longe de mim não
fosse meu estava pago já saque
o problema é que a mãe nunca o senhor
tem esquecido não estou falando isso não
tem coisas mais importantes é resolvida
mais ficamos com essa pendência que dá
como é que eu posso te dizer vamos fazer
assim essa orelha que é a passagem para
me encontrar o senhor uma rainha marruá
eu falei me dá um caminho e mostra luz e
foi aí que eu comecei a interpretar
todos os sinais ao meu favor
passou a luz em cima da minha casa sol
passou por dentro de uma goteira apontou
a porta pensando apontou a porta da
minha casa que eu fugi deus eu fui na
porta eu abril isso aqui ó atrás da
porta como eu morava no interior uma
enxada
falei a deus mandou enterrar essa xikrin
peguei a enxada pegar achei que eu votei
bem pese no meio pois só assim é que
quando é para esconder da manhã a gente
enterra direito
perfeito
uma mãe chegou em casa passou pelo
buraco não percebeu passou pela bandeja
não viu estava faltando um problema que
me parece que vem com um sensor na
cabeça dela que diz que alguma merda
aconteceu à mãe passando indicado normal
fez aquilo que aconteceu nessa casa é
pra cá e pra cá pra cá certeza uma duas
três quatro cinco
[Música]
olha
eu já sabia a merda que eu tinha feito
eu falei eu vou andar normal para não
perceber eu vim assim ó mamãe não quis
saber de conversa cada xícara que estava
aqui onde fui com a minha mãe com a cara
mais cínica que eu tinha visto aqui o
cheque
nunca nem vi eu
nem café elton minha senhora
molhou a minha cara diz não se fala de
dois não eles aqui tinha seis xícaras
eu só tô vendo 5 eu falei eu tinha
acabado de ver o time em seis mãe uma
duas três quatro cinco
[Música]
nossa mãe que doideira
estou deveras assustado com esta
situação a mãe pouco ela sabia que tinha
sido eu
ela olhou na minha cara a cara que o a
voz dela e lançou há cinco anos o que
ela me revela alguma coisa meu nome é
optimus prime leitores autobots eu
jurava mas ela me puxou pra perto no
fundo ele falou assim eu sou tua mãe eu
te conheço cada passo que tudo na terra
sem escuta que eu vou te dizer agora eu
vou encontrar onde escondeu essa chega
me de um gelo cara tão grande
eu estava olhando paranormal faltou
força das pernas fez um só que eu sabia
que eu tinha ajuda de deus na minha
cabeça
se deus é por nós quem será contra eles
né
olhei no fundo da minha mãe diz assim ó
eu quero é ver porque eu sabia que nós
eu tinha feito quando foi feito na minha
cabeça mas eu estava errado que o capeta
é astuta irmão ele engana as crianças
ele bota ali a vasilha
ele mandou só passar por cima pra
enganar menino deus ajuda as mães e
irmãos
deus ajuda não está na bíblia isso maria
capítulo 3 ciclo 7 falar
repita comigo mais alto deus ajuda as
mães
aleluia
como é que deus ajuda as mães se me
pergunta é o seguinte no piauí só chove
dezembro a março
é o período chuvoso no piauí era 23 de
agosto de uma chuva tão forte e bom
jesus do piauí que desenterrou o diabo
da xícara que tinha enterrado água foi
passando e foi revelando
a queda chega a mãe depois da chuva foi
limpar a casa escutando bruno e marrone
mamãe jogando aqui
o cisco para fora que ela olhou a xícara
em pé mas cadê o desempenho ea prova
pode matar eles a mãe quando villa nem
grita ela falou que as há há há
só assim ó eu já tinha esquecido eu
cheguei vim correndo quando eu vi a
xícara a minha alegria foi morrendo eu
fui chegando perto para esse ano
a mãe fez uma pergunta só uma o que é
isso aqui windows
veja bem esse é o único defeito de uma
mãe
o único a mãe é perfeita tira da boca
para o filho tá com fome e falta não tá
você comer entra na frente de uma bala
do carro se a agonia faz tudo
matei um defeito só eu queria que ele
levantasse a luta até por favor levante
a mão só as mães presentes por favor
você que é mãe lá em cima por favor
a palavra de hoje para você irmão
a mãe só tem um defeito só veja bem
ela quer que a gente fale e cale a boca
ao mesmo tempo
esse é o único defeito que uma mãe tem
único único perfeito como falou que é
isso aquilo que eu falei mãe apela cala
a boca
que merda isso aqui eu alemanha que
acaba você vai me explicar que merda
esta aqui eu fiquei calado olhou pra mim
e falou assim eu tô falando com quem
é pra eu falar cala a boca
pegou minha orelha começou a torcer
foi rodado na orelha foi rodando foi
rodando quando deu 14 volta na minha
orelha
falei pelo menos um ponto positivo ela
solta o de colo vou embora mas não
faltou não perdeu a décima quinta eu
falei vai arrancar o perguntar pra ela
eu olhei para fazer manhã a aula de
manhã a minha ordem é um só povo assiste
o mesmo show toda vez achei engraçado em
uma melhor na minha cara falou assim eu
estou fazendo com a orelha o quinto fez
com a orelha da minha xícara vingativa
mãe é vingativo tem coisa que mãe não
gosta
uma coisa que deixa mais estressado em
questão de segundos você está sem fazer
nada quero fazer sua mãe ficar com raiva
sente respire só na cabeça dela tem está
fazendo alguma coisa eu levantei estudos
ela mandar eu já ter feito ela vai lavar
louça jovem chuva e já cheguei a casa já
vá retirar a poeira já puxa a fim de ser
tudo falava meu carro do oficial não tem
carro
a lei tinha que ficar com muita raiva
você está sem fazer até o momento que a
gente passa os homens não se identifica
mais
sabe quando a gente deitar no sofá
assistindo o jogo que lhe shortinho azul
da educação física da prefeitura sem
cueca relaxado
para ficar mais relaxado a gente pega
essa perna esquerda que bota por cima da
cabeça do sofá assim o ovo da gente
começa desapegar da virilha e vai
descendo bem devagar sem pressa
almôndegas independente mas que ele quer
sair pelo lado do choque ele que
assistiu o jogo com você que assim quase
que ele pergunta é até quando joguei lá
quanto a mãe quando vem aqui e me dá um
tapa na cara dela sem fazer nada deitado
no sofá
ela chega no sul ou fala levanta o ovo
sob que mark não me dão aqui ó espirrou
sai pelo nariz está a passar cada uma
com a mãe quando eu fui dar um abraço na
mãe
um abraço a mãe lavava louça bem tarde
era umas meia noite aquele jantar em
família acabou tarde uma mãe se colavam
você sozinho todo mundo foi dormir eu
fui tomar banho lavar louça falei vou
dar um abraço na mãe
agora vai ser a mamãe por trás
eu cheguei contrato a minha mão foi bem
no meio do peito da mãe
eu não consigo descrever em palavras o
que eu senti por que eu gosto de abraçar
a mãe pela barriga
só que uma mãe só lava louça sem sutiã
ao peito vai barriga eu sentia aquela
sensação que pega na comida boiada sabe
ela é mamãe tá não só aquela sensação
que entorta a mão
até hoje essa história tem dez anos para
eu ter uma recaída de vez em quando eu
estou andando no meio da rua e fala pois
é tudo o que você que está assistindo
aqui no youtube não esquece de clicarem
gostei dessa povo entendeu porque o
youtube tabu gana casa porque falando
verdade a cultura está acusando clique
em gostei para desfazer o maior devedor
e comérico mais light sair pelo mundo tá
clique em gostei se inscreve no canal
isso aqui é o rio de janeiro viu galera
muito obrigado rio de janeiro que deus
abençoe vocês e leve você faz suas casas
'tamo junto' rio de janeiro é nóis é a
próxima a sair foram maravilhosos valeu
obrigado senhor acha de leste a oeste
o novo teste do sul sudeste e nordeste a
festa arranca com roupas acerta
desculpas às imagens da parte do prédio
e bocas usava na peça exposta roma e
roberto marques combate ramos gases
ataques a tiros chávez as bases dos
anfitriões o chicarito finas rodes a
repetirem nomes é produzir os seus
coisas na faixa dos microfones ao
sindivel baixo para se gostar com os
cursos de cadastros são civis e usar
seus legados para a cidade
era como uma das tiradas em uma raça que
só fossem empregadas acha ninguém mas
empata medo meu chapéu de palha 5 para a
batalha com força garra enxada se
caminha fortalece